how did they finally come together
because they were really some opposition
voices particularly in the Republican
side who said they did not want to do
this because it would look like a
bailout to Puerto Rico well that's right
and actually at this point I think some
conservative Republicans are still among
the most skeptical of the bill so we'll
see you know exactly who ends up going
along with it once we start seeing votes
on this but this is now a revised
version of a bill we've seen several
versions now over the past you know
nearly two months at this point so it's
been going on for a while yeah they had
to deal with both the skeptics from
conservatives who are worried about the
appearance of a bailout but also a lot
of Democrats who are worried about some
of the provisions in the bill that
either would slow down a restructuring
process or maybe too tough on on on the
Puerto Rican government and its ability
to carry out its affairs and address its
needs and so this negotiation was
ongoing it appears to have gotten
largely the way there but I will note
there might still be changes that all
sides are going to be trying to fight
over both in committee and on the floor
so you know I think it's a little
premature to say this thing is done but
this is a breakthrough it's still going
to be a little while though we might not
actually see the house passing it until
early june all right so yeah there's
still certainly many steps before we can
before it's implemented but Kevin
wouldn't give us them give us the big
bullet points on agreement here what's
so significant and the significance of
it what most of this didn't change from
the previous the previous versions of
the bill we're still time by creating a
financial control board that's going to
oversee any kind of debt restructuring
and also help sort of manage the help
the island manage its economy and its
finances you did see some important
tweaks and how that control board itself
will be appointed that's something the
White House and the Treasury Department
we're very concerned about and there are
a handful of other changes that are
quite technical in the way that was in
the way other elements of the debt were
treated it doesn't change the
prioritization though of how you know
these debts will be paid it does protect
sort of the current Puerto Rican
treatment of of where the general
obligation bond holders would stand so
these were important things that were a
couple more political provisions that
were stripped out to bring the Democrats
on board and I think that's why you saw
house mine
a leader nancy pelosi out there this
morning praising the bill saying that
that this is the right way forward Kevin
there's a big payment jus a two billion
dollar payment on July the first how
does this change the payment or
non-payment of that two billion dollars
it's a good question I don't think we
know yet but keep in mind we're still
looking at maybe early June for passage
in in the house and then it still has to
go to the Senate where where people have
been relatively quiet we don't get the
sense that many in the Senate really
want to sort of get in the way of this
but in the Senate it only takes one
senator to slow things down so it's
really unclear whether we'll see action
a bill in the President's desk by early
June or whether it could slip till till
later in the month remember if the
Senate changes anything that it has to
go back to the house for approval so we
could be looking at something that
starts the edge up pretty close to that
July one date and there's no immediate
money or or funding that's a part of
this bill so it's not like Puerto Rico
gets any extra dollars the day that this
thing is is signed so it's a little
unclear exactly whether the government's
going to be able to make those payments
even if the bill does pass and so I
think that's something everyone's going
to be looking at